erst bei uns in der sendung tatsächlich
auswandern ist halt immer so ein traum
endlich raus aus deutschland dann in ein
land wo tatsächlich immer die sonne
scheint und margit schlager bekannt aus
der sendung die auswanderer goodbye
deutschland hat das gemacht sie lebt
jetzt auf fuerte ventura und ist jetzt
zugeschaltet wie geht es ihnen gerade
diese vorgaben 39 grad ab es ist eine
ungewöhnliche vor dem tor vor allem
games zeit vier wochen sehr reich und
weil dieser nur gesehen hat weiß ich
habe ziemlich großes päckchen im moment
irgendwie zu organisieren dass wir hoch
weiter geht habe zwar hilfe bekommen
inzwischen allerdings ein völliges chaos
wenn wir es noch werde mehr aber eben
auch zwei helfer mehr
die müssen wir durchbringen wir deutlich
weniger kunden als früher
ja das ist so um die situation in der
ich mich befinde
das heißt sie kämpfen tatsächlich ums
überleben wahrscheinlich bleiben die
touristen weg und so wie sie sich das
vorgestellt hatten läuft es im moment
nicht wie viel geld haben sie noch in
der kasse - schulden also wir haben nach
der sendung über deutschland viele
hilfsbereite menschen gefunden die uns
weiterhelfen damit ist der schuldenberg
ein bisschen kleiner geworden allerdings
wächst der jeden tag so als
größenordnung wir brauchen wenn die
arbeiten dann fressen sie mehr
verbrauchen mehr energie brauchen wir am
tag selbst im sparbetrieb 150 euro
wegener bereiten hier hat man früher im
juli/august wirklich tolle bücher das
heißt dann muss der kunde auch mal
verschoben werden das ist jetzt so dass
wir sehr flexibel sind wären vier bis
acht kunden die woche das brauchen wir
eigentlich am park wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe und ehrlich zu sein den
ruf es werden wird oder in einem pferde
optional zu machen
den habe ich vor über 35 jahren ganz
bewusst abgelehnt weil ich weiß wie
schwer das ist
jetzt habe ich ihn halt und jetzt muss
ich durch bei a sagt muss auch b sagen
es ist eigentlich paradiesische auf vor
der natur
das ist niemals für alle touristen wir
haben im moment 24 positive fälle und
die größte anzahl davon
sind mit flüchtlingsbooten aus afrika
das heißt also wer hier urlaub machen
herkommen ist weitgehend sicher wir
haben auch keine masken pflicht hier bei
menschenansammlungen hingeht
es tut ja nicht jede maske aufzusetzen
absolut sieht wie geht es ihnen
persönlich was wo müssen sich sparen nur
noch wasser statt limonade und sie
sagten sie haben tatsächlich schulden
wie müssen sie sich jetzt einschränken
es ist nicht so dass sieht man glaube
ich auch dass ich von homburg aber
müssen ordnung
etwa 120 bis 150 euro im monat und davon
wo sie auf 200
so lud ja das ist wirklich sehr sehr
schwer
also dessen schwieriges schwierige
zeiten frau schlagen
vielen dank dass sie in dieser sendung
waren die internetleitung war da so ein
bisschen wackelig wünsche ihm trotzdem
alles gute und dass sie da gut über die
korona krise kommen also tatsächlich
werden gehört foto ventura bestes wetter
und keine masken pflegt tatsächlich